ich verlasse Kiew Richtung Nordosten 30
Kilometer außerhalb liegt horstommel
eine kleine Stadt mit großem Airport auf
den Straßen sehe ich viel Militär
Checkpoints zerstörte Häuser die Vororte
waren in den ersten Wochen des Krieges
heftig umkämpft hier fand sie statt die
Schlachtung Kiew wir fahren zum Airport
das erste was ich sehe ist das Gerippe
eines gewaltigen Flugzeugs
auf dem Rollfeld treffe ich wollonie mir
er war hier im Dienst als der Krieg
begann
am 24.02 etwa um 12 Uhr am Tag haben wir
den Lärm von Hubschraubern gehört und
hier sind russische Landungstruppen
angelandet
warum ist der Flughafen so wichtig
durch die Einnahme des Flughafens wäre
es möglich gewesen schnell Technik und
russische Truppen zu transportieren um
auf das Territorium der Ukraine
eindringen zu können
bei den heftigen Kämpfen wird Mirja der
Stolz der Ukraine das größte Flugzeug
der Welt völlig zerstört
wolodine nimmt uns mit zum Tower des
Flughafens seinem alten Arbeitsplatz der
51-Jährige war hier Chef der Lotsen
früher war hier alles schön
[Musik]
alles war schön und sauber es war hell
hier
und was passiert jetzt
dieses Gebäude wird höchstwahrscheinlich
komplett abgerissen
denn es ist fast unmöglich dass wieder
aufzubauen
einen Monat lang kämpften Russen und
Ukrainer hier bis nur noch Trümmer Tod
und Staub Leben
tausende Patronenhülsen zeigen wie
massiv die Schlacht war die Minen wurden
zwischenzeitlich geräumt zwischen all
dem Schutz finden wir trotzdem überall
noch Spuren der russischen Soldaten
das ist auch von den Russen
ja das ist eine Essensration von den
Russen
wir klettern auf den Tower
von hier oben wird die strategische
Bedeutung des Flughafens klar die Nähe
zu Hauptstadt
von hier hatten wir einen tollen Blick
auf Kiew ihr PIN Butcher
waren sie im Bunker damals
ja als wir einmal rausging haben wir
Russen gesehen von Angesicht zu
Angesicht hatten sie Angst
klar die haben gesagt haben Sie keine
Angst wir sind gekommen um sie zu
befreien wir haben gefragt wovon sie uns
befreien wollen denn faktisch hat man
uns vom guten Flughafen befreit von
hervorragenden Flugzeugen so ist
anscheinend die russische Welt die
befreien Leute von allem was sie lieben
von allen befreit zu werden was Ihnen
wichtig ist das muss noch die Anwohner
direkt neben dem Flughafen erleben ich
treffe die 73-Jährige Nadia Koslova in
ihrem zerschossen im Häuserblock
hier wird gerade humanitäre Hilfe
gebracht die Leute brauchen warmes Essen
weil Sie keine Möglichkeit haben etwas
zu kochen die Häuser sind zerstört all
die Leute hier mussten aus diesen
Häusern raus aus denen die gebrannt
haben da ist alles verbrannt einige
Leute verließen die Stadt dann sind sie
zurückgekommen und da ist nichts mehr
viele Menschen schämen sich auch Nadia
fühlt sich wie eine Bettlerin seit vor
allem Tschetschenen in Haus Tommel
wüteten
das hier ist unser Haus
ich kann Ihnen den Keller zeigen wo wir
gesessen haben 38 Tage lang ohne Wasser
ohne Brot
ich war die bis Kleber
die schlimmsten Wochen ihres Lebens
erlebte sie hier
eingepfercht in zwei dunklen
Kellerräumen
mehr als 100 Leute waren hier
saßen die Leute wir saßen auf den Röhren
jetzt ist hier alles aufgeräumt
damals saßen hier überall Leute auch
hier
da haben wir auch geschlafen
es gab auch ein kleines Mädchen vier
Monate alt
sogar Kinder ja acht Kinder sie waren
sechs acht zehn Jahre alt und was haben
sie die ganze Zeit gemacht wir
versuchten am Leben zu bleiben die
Tschetschenen kam hier rein alle mit
Masken und Maschinengewehren stellen Sie
sich das vor klar wir hatten Angst alle
Telefone wurden uns weggenommen
anderthalb Monate waren wir nicht
erreichbar
und jetzt was denken sie über den Krieg
was kann ich davon halten der Krieg ist
das Böse
er hat einen Not und Leid gebracht
das ist einfach nicht normal dass sowas
im 21 Jahrhundert passiert
den Glauben an eine Zukunft aber hat sie
nicht verloren die Schlacht von
horstommel haben die Ukraine am Ende
gewonnen und in der diasstraße gibt es
ein Lichtblick direkt nebenan entstehen
auf den Trümmern neue Wohnblöcke für die
Opfer des Krieges